appreciate that very much but we're here
to honor the authors this afternoon and
we will make time to answer your
questions at least some of them near the
end I'm told we want to end this session
no later than 2:45 it's now 1:55 so
you've got a lot of ground to cover and
we'll do the very best we can but I do
want to emphasize I appreciate that
round of applause but we're here to
honor these offers Bob Huffaker is
co-author of when the news went live
Dallas 1963 and he broadcast televisions
first murder when Jack Ruby shot the
assassin Lee Oswald his book John
Powell's is cited as a seminal
scholarship about the novelist and his
work has appeared in the southern
humanities Review the Dallas Observer
true West senior advocate and Texas
Parks & Wildlife Bill Mercer you should
stand up here I'm not sure what it
conceived a handi bill is co-author of
when the news went live Dallas 1963 he
confronted Lee Harvey Oswald at the
Dallas Police Headquarters in a midnight
press showing but otherwise be called a
prep walk these days he informed of the
assassin that police had charged him
with the president's murder he was later
the voice of the Dallas Cowboys Chicago
White Sox Texas Rangers University of
North Texas and the Cotton Bowl Mercer
among other things is honored in the
Texas radio Hall of Fame let's have a
round applause for pure emotion
George Phoenix is a co-author of when
the news went live Dallas 1963 after
leaving KRLD and Dallas he was a
speechwriter for governor Preston Smith
pride of West Texas and for congressman
JJ pickled the pride of right here in
Austin
he was also executive assistant to u.s.
senator Lloyd Bentsen Phoenix is the
publisher of Texas weekly which he
founded thus have a round of applause
for George pinion West wise it was
another the co-authors of when the news
went live Dallas 1963 he was a
well-known baseball announcer for the
old Liberty Broadcasting System in the
1940s and 1950s keep in mind he started
when he was five years old and has
written for Sports Illustrated
time and Life West wise served five
years as the distinguished mayor of
Dallas so let's have a round of applause
for all of his help we recognize it's a
little hard for some people particularly
in front to see so if you don't mind
this is going to be fairly relaxed any
time the gentleman you want to sit down
you can sit otherwise you know now and
when somebody has a question or whatever
you can stand if you get a feeling
disconnected from the audience here in
front just stand of your own free will
now I want you to know that they have
the moderators duties during the panel
if these have come out in a complete and
unabridged edition I'm sure but there
are a couple of things that I need to
make very clear to you and that is book
signing information 15 minutes after the
end of this panel the author's will sign
their books at the TBF signing tenth
which has a new location this year it's
now on Congress Avenue directly in front
of the Capitol between 10th and 11th
streets Congress Avenue in front of the
Capitol between 10th and 11th children's
authors were signing the children's of
10th the signings take place outside
because the state of Texas does not
permit private groups to conduct
fundraising on state property if you
want to have a book signed you need to
go to the 10th so mark that well
and let me point out at the beginning
here and I may also do at the end that
the mission of the Texas Book Festival
along with celebrating books and authors
the festival benefits the public
libraries of Texas 25% of proceeds from
the sales of all books and merchandise
in the signing tents goes to the
festival's funds for rewards for public
libraries the festival has contributed
more than 1.6 five million dollars to
five hundred and fifty libraries all
over the state and I want to remind you
that to visit the Book Fair southwest of
the capital which is more than 130
booths with booksellers publishers
library organizations a great children's
area municipal entertainment and food
don't forget to go to the Book Fair was
over there briefly this morning as I
walked over here and it's really
something to see so with all of that out
of the way let me seek your indulgence
in one other thing and that is I love
the Texas Book Festival but on the
beautiful Saturday afternoon such as
this I want you to know that I'm here
because Mary Margaret therapy who was
one of the originators of the Book Fair
and it remains the leader asked me to be
here so if you say what in the world is
Dan Rather doing here mayor Margate for
every asked me to be here and that's why
I'm here now let's talk about the book
this is a book that has been out for a
little more than a year it's sold out
and its first printing before the books
even got to booksellers in most cases
it's gone through a second printing
which is also virtually sold out and is
never being made to put it into the
third printing which I'm sure will be
successful let's go with the co-authors
first let me ask each one the same
question or some version of Bom what do
you think is the importance of this book
well we we think the book is important
because it shows the difference between
the way news was covered 40 years ago
and the way it's covered today
it also shows as well as we were able to
do how things really happened that day
in Devon now the Oliver Stone movie is
not at all true and it's that we all
believe very firmly that the Oliver
Stone movie JFK was a great disservice
to American history he's very well
filmed but it just didn't happen that
way and we were there
dan was there and all of my three
co-authors were there for 40 years
people asked me when I was going to get
busy and write this book and I was
writing other things you heard Texas
Parks and Wildlife as one of my credits
that article was about fire ants and
with with which I am intimate and so
finally they just challenged me to write
this book or shut up
so I I never felt that I was capable of
telling this entire story because I was
only where I was I was at the motorcade
that main and a Kurd broadcasting it
live after whisks had broadcast it at
lemon and in wood I was suddenly then at
Parkland Hospital with George Phoenix
the saddest scene that I have ever seen
and had to report it was very difficult
to do and the covering this tragedy
changed our lives all of us in our
various ways it sent me off to be an
English professor for the next couple of
decades and
I never dared tell my English students
that I had covered the assassination
because I knew that I could never get
through teaching one class of English if
I did so I hid out and and taught
English figured it was better to teach
the kids than to report tragedy but
somebody has to report it and that day
we certainly did I would like to say a
word to about dan Rather who has been
one of our stalwart journalists with
more courage than most certainly in this
entire country for a long time
and he started out at Sam Houston State
when I started out at a am about 25
miles away it's an honor to have Dan
here today and it's an honor that he
wrote the foreword to this book we all
feel very close to it we're trying to
show as best we can
what really happened when News changed
radio had gotten us through World War
two and for the first time on November
22nd 1963 that job of holding the nation
together fell to television and we had
to do it in the clunky old ways of 40
years ago and that is part of what this
book is about thank you very much Bob
and thank you for those kind words
undeserved as they are I do appreciate
them Bill Mercer another of the
co-authors remember the name of this
book is when the news went live Dallas
1963 they oh mercy thank you dad I still
teach some at the University of North
Texas and it's interesting to try to
tell your students about the time that
we spent back in those days in the 50s
and 60s doing live commercials in studio
using a little bell + Howell 16
millimeter camera and all these things
that they just don't comprehend I think
the thing that I keep telling them is
and I've told all my students for the
thirty years that I've taught learn
everything you can in college if you
want to be a reporter as much as you can
because you just never know what the
what's going to be thrust on you and you
have to rise to that occasion think
about Michaels who rose to the occasion
during the World Series in San Francisco
people were surprised that Al Michaels
could report on an earthquake at least a
reporter doing sports it's the same sort
of thing and so the four of us were
young reporters at KRLD in nineteen that
fit while I started there in 53 this was
10 years later I was sort of on the
bench player at the time I was doing
baseball minor league baseball in Dallas
and football and other things and then
the offseason I come into the news room
and play newsman we did it all so we did
a interview show but when this happened
all of a sudden you'd better click in
and I think for all of us it did we were
sent to do certain jobs we tried our
best to do them but to this day I can't
remember the time I spent on the third
floor of the Dallas police station I
can't I can visualize being there and
seeing people I can't remember a
question I ever asked and once in a
while I see myself but not very often I
was watching about a year ago and they
were doing a special on the
assassination and there we were on the
third floor and I said well maybe I'm
there but I didn't see myself they'd
bring somebody out the door of the
detectives door and that people are
jammed into the hall the door closes and
they had pushed me behind the door that
was the kind of situation that we faced
first time for me ever having to put up
with a whole bunch of people who came in
from everywhere to be reporters on this
tremendous and sad story so it was a it
was a battle it was to test did we
really have the journalistic ability to
handle this I think so I hope so we
tried our best and I think that's all
any reporter can do is try its best
I was honored to think back on the
things that happened and that the few
things that I covered these guys covered
most of it and some of our people who
are not with us any longer but it was a
time to step up and assume
responsibility and we tried and I hope
you enjoy the book
thank you Bill
George Phoenix is next I can't I want to
underscore that the name of this book
which we cannot emphasize too much is
when the news went live Dallas 1963
let's welcome now George Phoenix one of
the co-authors George how was the newest
greenest reporter in Dallas I've been
there six weeks got thrown into that and
Mauro's I'm just a foot soldier
reporter cameraman but I'm proud of what
we did Dallas was an edgy town I got
punched out three times that year partly
because my personality and partly
because of the city twice during the
covering the assassination events I
hitched arrived with total strangers now
wants to cover this story and wants to
get back from the story we were just
having to fly by the seat of our pants
and learn on the job it was a pivotal
time in the way America got its knees
until that at time if it wasn't in the
local newspaper you didn't believe it
Fort Worth star-telegram ran seven
special editions that day and there was
a sellout crowd waiting for every one of
them but they couldn't keep up things
were happening too fast
and television came into its own our
station was only ten years old at the
time our technology was pretty primitive
compared to today but he got the job
done I think I said I know bob was the
first murder ever broadcast live on
until the
I think my film that they ran in slow
motion over and over
oh I didn't tell you that I know Ruby
shot Oswald because he was standing
right next to me and when he stepped out
in the crowd and shot him they interview
I'm nearly famous Dan interviews the
film is shot by Joe Phoenix close
they ran I got my Christmas bonus that
year and it was eight dollars and sixty
two cents it was based strictly on the
amount of time I had worked there which
was middle of October we're pretty sure
that Oswald did it to CBS I'm a c-span
and SMU School of Journalism at the 30th
anniversary invited 300 local reporters
to come to a day-long seminar and they
polled us and it was unanimous
we all thought Oswald was the shooter
they polled the Dallas Police Department
the same way and it was also unanimous
and I suppose you could argue that we're
just covering our backsides because we
didn't turn up anybody else but I think
the issues been examined over
and over and it stands it was a tough
time to be a reporter we found out later
in talking to each other that we were so
busy doing our jobs we didn't have time
to grieve and I still to this day it
choked up thank you about what happened
to our country to that family but you
just had to press on and do what you did
sorry old guys tend to tear up a little
bit
Thanks
thank you George West wise he is the
cleanup hitter for this group because
his last name starts as W and they do
this in alphabetical order but let me
remind you that West wise was and
remains by reputation was a great play
by play men of all time including
recreating baseball games I know that
that's hard to imagine but there was a
time when you set in a studio the likes
at West wise did and Western Union sent
you a sort of summary of the game and
you had to imagine it put it through the
micro and further people a real skill
the reason for bringing it up now is
that Wes and I know he will take this as
the compliments and he attended he's
also batting cleanup because bluntly put
ladies in general and West wise could
talk a dog off a meat wagon West lies
first I've got to get this off my chest
isn't this a great day in this festival
something else beautiful day like this
man oh man and get somebody like Dan
Rather back to us guys talking over old
times what could be better the life is
wonderful it really is and I'm just so
happy to be a part of this book festival
you know it's hard to know where to
start exactly but you know Dan pointed
out I've went 35 years in journalism and
finally decided it was time to get into
something honest so I got into politics
but but this room right here is is
really part of what Texas politics in
Texas government is all about and it's
just a thrill to be a part of this
probably one of the things that I am
best known for as far as the coverage of
the assassination of President Kennedy
is concerned was when I was signed by
the news director Eddie Barker to try to
retrace the steps of Lee Harvey Oswald
the day after the assassination and I
parked the KRLD station wagon which was
clearly marked on the side with the CBS
eye on the side with KRLD was the CBS
station of course and I saw out of the
corner of my a person in a dark blue
suit and a fedora hat that would later
become familiar more or less trotting
and waddling toward the station wagon
where I was sitting behind the wheel and
it was Jack Ruby I associate with only
the finest people in Dallas as you can
tell and Jack said you know as we all
were saying visit this it's a shame and
isn't it awful that mrs. Kennedy might
have to come back and testify in this
trial and I said Jack that will never
happen that's just not going to happen I
told him then about my having taken
pictures of the Western silence which
would be were to be given by the city of
Dallas to for Caroline and John John the
Kennedy children and as I said that
tears came to his eyes as which was
happening to many people in Dallas and
elsewhere on those days and as a result
of that confrontation I became a witness
in the Ruby trial both for the defense
and for the court for the
for the prosecution the prosecution
wanting to show of course why was he
there at that time the day after the
assassination and the defense wanting to
show that he showed him ocean by the
tears in his eyes and as a result of
that Jack Ruby became one of our best
sources after that confrontation during
the remainder of the time and of course
there are people who will say well
that's taking advantage of friendship
that perhaps you shouldn't do in
journalism I say that's that's a lot of
baloney because you do have to take
advantage of your contacts and your your
the people that you know in the city and
so forth and that's what I believe KRLD
and CBS at that time did better than
anybody we were able to take advantage
of the people we knew personally in
Dallas of politics and Dallas government
in Dallas the police department and were
able to bring to the world the best in
my opinion the best overall treatment of
the assassination of President Kennedy
and those three fateful days in all our
lives during the time of the
assassination all the way through
President Kennedy's funeral one of the
best things that has have happened to us
I think is us for getting together we
didn't know what each other was doing
I'm impressed by what they have have
done and I'm impressed the way we put it
out in the book and I think we also
showed that television really did come
of age and in a day when we didn't have
the immediacy of the satellite when we
had to shoot the film run the film into
the station get it
souped as we call it back in those days
get it developed then then edit the film
then write the the commentary to the
film then put it on the air that kind of
one-person journalism just doesn't exist
today in this day of satellite TV and I
think the TV and in general does a good
job overall but I think the book will
show you some ideas that we have as to
what journalism TV journalism could be
doing better and I think we did it
pretty darn well back in those days well
I'd say some more stuff and I want to
say one more thing it is really a
pleasure to have
back in town we reminisce a little bit a
few minutes before we came in here would
you believe that as youngsters and I do
mean youngsters he and I had did a
football game back in Texas a high
school football game and I don't
remember whether I did the play-by-play
and he did the color or whether was the
other way around
but I think we taught each other a lot
Thank You Wes for those in our
television audience and those who are
here as one who's dabbled in books
myself over the years there's nothing
like showing you the book it's when the
news went live Dallas 1963 Taylor trade
published it these general will be
signing their books but not in this
building for reasons outlined to you
before remember they'll be in their own
signing tent when this is over what I'd
like to pick up on one of the things
that you mentioned and we'll ask the
others perhaps to chime in on this
there's a widespread belief I'm a
believer in it that if it wasn't a case
of television journalism coming of age
and what we call the four dark days in
Dallas Friday when the president was
assassinated Saturday Sunday when the
assassin was assassinated and Monday
when we had the National funeral if it
wasn't a case of television coming in
age it was certainly time when
television years first God's what we
would call consensus credibility I'd
like you to come back up to microphone
and we'll ask the others to chime in on
this what made it so what made it so
what gave it the credibility during the
length and breadth of those four days as
you have pointed out when the coverage
was live extended live news coverage of
a sort that we had never had before
nationally dan this is going to be a
little bit of bragging I'm afraid here
it's because of for reporters like these
here and I have count myself among them
we were experienced journalists we were
not conspiracy minded and we are not
today by the way we we went into the
thing with a weather
the end of the whole coverage of the
entire four days we went into it with
the idea we're going to do what is
honest we're going to report it in the
best way we can in the clearest way we
can and we're going to be truthful and I
think we really accomplished that and I
think but not only those reporters for
KRLD and for CBS I think the other
reporters for the other local radio
stations and TV stations and some of the
other networks did a good job - Thank
You question Georgian likes you to come
back up the microphone and I don't want
to belabor this point about television
reaching it's its moment of credibility
in the country I think it's important
for people to understand many people in
this room remember the day but some
people in this room are not we're not a
memory age or weren't born during that
time but set the scene for us at what
the kind of hammer to the heart that the
Kennedy assassination was when you first
heard it you know it's a common still
common currency in conversation to say
where were you at the moment that you
learned that President Kennedy was
assassinated but said give us some
context and perspective of where the
country was at that time including the
fact that President Kennedy was our
first president born in the 20th century
that every president before President
Kennedy had been born in the 19th
century he was the first president born
in the 20th century and there was this
whether one liked him or not whether one
agreed with his policies are not had a
lot of people didn't there was this our
youth and a young family about in that
take off from there and give us a little
context as you saw it that day it he
they call it Camelot they were young
vibrant hope for America old political
ideas and I would say ours at the
trademart I'd filmed them come
the end of the airport and is a day like
today beautiful they were beautiful
we were feeling good I got to the
trademart out in the crowd and a crowd
start buzzing and a woman started crying
and I said what's going on she had a
little transistor radio she said he's
been hit he's been yet president I
thought wrong bottle
I never thought gun hard the sirens
going over on Stemmons freeway and our I
just instinctively knew something was
happening
I saw Air Force guy running out I jumped
in the car with him hitch that's the
first rider hits to the Parkland
Hospital and he was pounding the back
seat we have driver and he was sent me
shot him they shot this over I said shot
who he said Kennedy - our president and
we got there and there was a somber
crowd outside Bob and some of the others
who have been in the motorcade were
inside getting the story and those of us
outside were just standing around in
shock and you didn't want to believe it
you just did not want to believe it but
we had we had to come to our senses and
do what they're paying us to be but I
remember when Secret Service came out
and start moving us back away from the
emergency entrance I was going to be too
far away to film anymore because my
short lens so I broke from the crowd and
ran into the Parkland and the whole time
I was running I was thinking I hope they
don't shoot me we really didn't know if
it was a national conspiracy to kill
everyone in government are just the lone
assassin but it was a terrible terrible
feeling in your heart can't really
explain
bill I want to get back to the book
itself we may come back that's such an
important one that you raised about in
the first minutes and hours after the
assassination of President Kennedy
there's no question it was a it was a
reasonable question to ask was this
something standalone if you will or was
it part of a wider conspiracy it may be
hard now with the passing of time
particularly for people who weren't
there people don't remember or other
decent intending people to say well what
a ridiculous thing to think it wasn't a
ridiculous thing to think at all thank
God it was what it appeared to be and so
far as anybody's able to been able to
prove and I think it was but there there
was this sense and maybe bill you want
to pick up on that there was this sense
in the first certainly first hours I
would say in the first several days of
what is going on here if you can build
this is such a strong point in your book
when television went live Dallas 1963
the role of a reporter you will reporter
you were there all of this was swirling
about you give us a sense of what the
environment was how you approached your
job as a shoe leather and make telephone
calls get out there head down tail up
working reporter give us some sense of
that let me let me back up just a bit
most of you who are our age may recall
that Dallas was a great there was a
great deal of strife in Dallas
right-wing groups Birch Society various
other people who were constantly causing
uproar at our radio station on our
interview show who were addict Lee
against the United Nations Kennedy hip
Adlai Stevenson West covered that yet at
least Stevenson with a placard we knew
there was an element of Dallas but not
all of Dallas tell us was not a mean
City basically but there was an element
that came to roost there that bothered
us all four of us have talked about this
I came back to University that night
Thursday night thinking oh I hope those
people don't come out and throw eggs at
a Mart or do something nasty to stand up
and and hit the car or do something bad
never thought about shooting it well so
it all happened and I think it's
reporters it didn't sink in for a while
but then we began to think okay which
group really orchestrated this and then
back up on my mind I thought some of
these right-wing groups said I naturally
because of the association that we had
with them and the way that they had
yelled and screamed around Allison on
our air but then you know we were in the
dark all we could do was go ahead and
cover this thing as a reporter on the
third floor and I'll back up a little
again because we talked about television
coming live that Friday night they ran
the van over to the police department
the camera was brought up to the third
floor on the police station of the
detective area they ran a cable to the
truck and microwave a live signal back
to the station which went on to CBS and
all evening from about seven o'clock on
I was over there we were shooting we
were doing everything live I didn't have
a four man I didn't have a director I
didn't have any help
I had one engineer who was down camera
it was so totally different than today
my instinct as a reporter was okay
everybody I know I'm going to ask a
question about what happened you know
the old who what when where why and how
and that's what I did I just went into
journalism and asked every district
attorney that the police and everybody
do you know who did who was behind this
no we only know this man he hasn't said
anything he never did talk and that live
picture
for six hours then we went to the press
room in the bottom of the basement
they brought they brought Oswell it's
not funny really but to think of it
today it's hilarious because there were
200 people
reporters everyone of masculine
questions the same time so the press
conference lasted about a minute and a
half or two minutes and I was down on my
knees in front of Lee Harvey and you
know nobody nobody could hear me except
the camera and this guy next to me said
have you been charged with anything and
he said no and I looked up at him I said
yeah you've been charged with the murder
of the president and he gave me that
kind of look so nobody heard that
except the people watching live on
television and I didn't even think about
it that would just seem to be the thing
to do I don't know who I don't know if
anybody asked him and I imagine they did
who got you to do this who were you
working for they may have we never I
never found out I never heard about it
but we all had an impression the last
thing was CBS radio asked me to go out
one day and they said go over to the
triple underpass and interview a
conservative okay I'm waiting
now you think about that I got to go
over and find a conservative I couldn't
find one in this room really very well
so we go over there we go over there an
engineer and I'm the engineer says how
the hell are we gonna find a
conservative they don't wear signs I
said I know so we went over young
reporter I've done a lot of interviews
with coaches and stuff so I knew about
interviewed so we walk around there
weren't many people that day long story
short we're just about ready to leave
and I look up Main Street there comes a
gentleman over the crest of the hill God
was on the reporters side that day man
with a fedora hat nice gray overcoat
suit best umbrella briefcase I said well
let's wait a minute
he comes out and he comes down the hill
and I said just let him go there for a
while so he walks around he's looking at
the flowers were everywhere who may
recall there were the little notes on
them and he was reading the little notes
so I said okay here's my chance so I
walked up to him introduced myself and I
said sir you looked like a very busy
professional man
was taking some time out to come down
here today could you tell me what you're
thinking what you're why you came down
here and he said and it's in the book I
hated John Kennedy and went on to
explain that he would never want him
dead that he was sorry that he came down
to apologize reporters are lucky
sometimes and I think that's what we
were lucky to be in the wrong place at
the right time
you know I have a feeling at least to
speak for myself we could go on a long
time here but we are at the mercy of the
clock and this clock at the end of hall
says it's 2:30 - we are gonna go to
questions Bob I wonder if you will allow
me to call on the audience for questions
and make sure that they direct the first
question to Bob who didn't have his
second run around here so we're gonna
open up the questions now a couple of
things remember the name of the book is
when the news went live Dallas 1963 and
we have we have time to take questions I
do have this request the acoustics in
this room are not ideal so if you have a
question if you could make sure that if
you're in the rear come down a little
bit and also speak very loudly so we'll
open up the questions and the first
question will be directed to Bob
Huffaker
a co-author of when the news went live
Dallas 1963 Liz carpenter who lived an
extraordinary part of this period but
both before and after the assassination
of President Kennedy Liz
God want to repeat the question because
it's a very good one listen you never
cease to amaze me and how vivid your
memory remains I suffer news timers
disease about once every other minute
but Liz Cobra has a very good memory for
those of you in the back thrust of this
question was will we aware and it's
asking Bob where you're aware of the
difference between the initial wire
service reports keep in mind
particularly I don't mean this
patronizing the wall at all but young
people in that era there were two main
wire services The Associated Press and
the United Press and if you think the
competition in television today is
fierce and it is it could not be more
fierce than it was between The
Associated Press and United Press and if
you remember there were two legendary
reporters there Merriman Smith United
Press and Jack Bell with The Associated
Press they were in a pool car if you
will I won't get too deep into this but
because all reporters could not be up
front of the motorcade they were in
what's called a pool car and there was
only one telephone in that car and when
the shots rang out Merriman Smith God
rest his soul was a great reporter
Jack Bell was a great reporter crammed
into this one car with Secret Service
people and Smith got to the phone first
and he did what any reporter would do
which is he held the phone for as long
as he could with Jack Bell threatening
to hit him with a tire - about every 15
seconds so there was quite a discrepancy
in time between the two wire service
reports and there was some discrepancy
keep in mind that they didn't know much
Merriman Smith's lead and his follow up
lead on the day of the assassination are
rightfully still taught in journalism
schools as a classic case of dictation
journalism but now Bob the question is
were you aware of the difference in
timing and the difference of those
reports as you segue into your own
duties that day well no not at all
because I was at Maine enacted
broadcasting the motorcade life and West
was that living and in would bill was on
the air on the twelve o'clock television
news and George was at the trademart
waiting for the president's arrival
someone asked me in fact you're asking
about the difference in the two UPI and
AP and we were totally unaware of that
most of us except for our people who
were there in our news studios watching
those wires we were out there sending
information live to our you know we were
broadcasting it live the whole time so
we didn't have a chance at that time to
watch what was going on with the with
the wire services I was asked about a
week ago or two weeks ago didn't you
read any newspapers during that time and
my answer is absolutely not we were we
were too busy and for many years I think
some of us had a less clear picture
there of the entire tragic scene
nationwide than people who were sitting
at home watching television because we
were all there and all I knew was what
was going on at the police station and
it was all very strange I must say
Nelson Benton Dan's right-hand man was
with me at police headquarters
the police were my beat and so I knew a
lot of the police officers and knew the
ropes
and each of our stations and all of the
newspapers in Dallas by that time had
received at least one or two bomb
threats and things were getting very
close to being out of hand
particularly the scene in the police
station with hundreds of reporters and
the police were trying to be polite they
were trying to preserve Dallas's damaged
reputation and I remember sitting
alongside Nelson Benton on the floor
across from the elevators whose doors
were opening and closing ahead of us and
we had just realized that there was no
identification check being done on
anyone who was coming in this was the
day before
Oswald was shot and I said to Nelson
well what if somebody stepped out of one
of those elevators and simply began to
rape the crowd with with automatic
weapons fire and Nelson who had flown a
bomber in World War two looked at me and
we looked at each other for a time and
then we got up and moved from that time
on we tried to keep our cameraman and
everyone in a rather safe position oh
yes
right
and appreciates the question I've got it
and don't mean to erupt but I am aware
the clock is running and folks we're
gonna have about five more minutes maybe
one more question but we will get out of
here 2:45 but I do want to come to your
question I hope you will understand say
that my role here is to put forth my
friends who wrote this book co-authored
this book West wise five years
distinguished mayor of Dallas not only
does he have the most political office
holding experience of anybody up here he
has the only political office experience
of anybody holding up here us come up in
West is someone who loved Dallas with a
deep and abiding passion with great
respect for it
let me say that as I've just pointed out
you know we weren't aware we had a laser
beam focus on covering the story we
weren't aware of very much of what
anybody else was doing except our own
role if you will it's not coming from
the question I don't remember hearing a
single severide analysis during that
period he was a mentor of mine great
journalist someone whom I'm still
involved I just don't remember what you
refer to it may have it I'm not saying
it didn't happen if you know what
happened it happened but Wes address it
what happened there was unquestionably
in the first few days I would say it
lasted some weeks and months in some
cases of a what I will put in quotation
marks as a blame Dallas syndrome Dan I
believe the best illustration that I can
give of that would actually have come 10
years after the assassination when I was
mayor of Dallas and went to the US
Conference of Mayors meeting in Chicago
and after a long session of going into
many of the issues of the day for local
and national government a group of
Mayors was standing around at the end of
the day and just chatting sipping on a
few drinks perhaps beer or whatever and
suddenly out of nowhere a mayor from the
Midwestern City looked at me and said
mr. mayor how does it feel to be mayor
of the city that killed the president
well I was already being dead used with
ten
in later stories by the journalist an
ideal I would be when I went to Chicago
but I'm it first impulse was to strike
out physically of course but I knew if I
did that this would be national
publicity that we again would not have
been in favor of Dallas later on during
that same session every one of those
mayor's came to me and said hey look
that was a low blow it was completely
unfair it could have happened to my in
my city just as well and we want to
apologize the next morning the mayor who
made the statement came to me and he
said man have I been catching hell from
life all of my layers and he said I
realized why and I want to apologize and
he stated his hand and of course we
shook hands that probably would
illustrate better that with your point
Dan than anything that happened to me
one more thing people who talk about the
assassination even today get choked up I
have not talked to a single journalist
broadcast trend who hasn't said that
sometime after all of this was over that
he didn't he or she didn't get alone
somewhere in a corner and cry sometimes
uncontrollably it was it was an
emotional experience for us all one that
we wished we didn't have to cover but of
course was a privilege for us to have
been able to cover thank you
folks let me just say that I think we
should give a tremendous round of
applause to all four of these offers
authors Bob Huffaker
Bill Mercer George Phoenix and Wes wise
for a really outstanding book and one
one man's opinion a book that's going to
stand the test of time that people who
were very well referring to for a very
long time to come let's give them a
great hand for this great
good
the name of the book is when the news
went live Dallas 1963 don't forget that
the author's will be signing book
signings 15 minutes after the end of
this panel 15 minutes from now it's on
Congress Avenue directly in front of the
Capitol between 10th and 11th streets
thank you very much for being this
afternoon
Godspeed as you go